he hopes these words can topple
Venezuela's government opposition leader
Juan Guido swore himself in as interim
president as thousands cheered him on
the aim is ending this usurpation and
this treasonous government and holding
free elections if this happens then let
God and let the nation reward us and if
not then let them demand otherwise why
DOS declaration comes as hundreds of
thousands rallied across Venezuela to
support the opposition they call
president maduro's government
illegitimate and blame him for their
country's economic collapse but as their
protests continued deadly violence
spread several demonstrators have been
reported killed amid clashes with police
while authorities clamped down on
protesters Venezuela's opposition is
getting fresh support elsewhere
president Trump joined a growing list of
leaders who say they recognize Juan Y
doe as Venezuela's interim president
Trump tweeted the announcement and wrote
Venezuelans have spoken out against
Maduro and his regime and demanded
freedom and the rule of law
president Maduro has hit back by vowing
to cut all ties with Washington he told
all US diplomatic staff to leave the
country within 72 hours Adam and the
White House rejects out of Venezuela
they go enough interventionism there is
dignity here and here there are people
to defend this land but the opposition
says they have the claim to defending
the country from the Maduro government
one Guido says he intends to act as
interim president only until new and
fair elections can be held ok where is
this headed Eduardo Mendez from DW Latin
America joins us in the studio this
morning good morning Eduardo what can
you tell us about Juan Guido the the
opposition leader and how much public
support does he have well one way though
is the newest face the freshest face in
a long row of opposition leaders that
are in prison or that had to leave the
country and he's the new hope the clear
new face of hope for Venezuelans and I
say the the freshest but he also has
shifted a bit the rhetoric of how the
opposition is presenting itself in
Venezuela especially because he is he
has a more calm way to transmit his
message he is not so pushing forward
like former positions leader did and so
he's trying to to get some sort of
dialogue though he's very insistent in
his message and trying to you know get
this dictatorship of commanding
Venezuela okay and he has support of
course a president Trump has backed him
we have a platform of regional States
and was the Lena group really me group
is well throwing their weight behind
guardo this is the Foreign Minister of
Canada part of that group Chrystia
Freeland let's have a listen to what
she's saying so let me say on behalf of
Canada that we recognize and express our
full support for the interim presidency
of
whele assumed by the president of the
National Assembly one glide though in
compliance with the Constitution of
Venezuela and we the members of the Lima
group are preparing a fuller written
statement which we hope will come up
very soon it's an important day for
Venezuela and I'm grateful for the
Solidarity of the Lima group in speaking
out on this and where will this regional
solidarity benefit one guido well its
original solidarity but it's not
complete solidarity in the region
because you have important states like
Mexico Cuba Uruguay were not supporting
one way though and and this opposition
movement and also there is more to just
in the region I mean on the one hand you
have the u.s. saying yeah we're fully
supporting him but the u.s. one
important buyer of anis well and oil so
I think we have to observe very
carefully what other powers are doing
like China Russia who have very strong
interest in Venezuela so it's not that
clear I mean in the regional support
what does it mean and more than the
diplomatic intentions there's not more
to that until now and even Europe is
playing a very weak role if if I have to
put it clearly they're chickening a
little bit just with with yeah
statements but you have people dying
right now at this moment the Venezuelan
government is killing people protesting
defending democracy that is not more
existent in Venezuela when you have yet
to put a clear label on Maduro Midori's
a dictator the election subject of last
year were not fair and were not
transparent and that's what why one way
though claimed himself according to the
constitution event as well as a present
so you have a dictator and you have a
very weak international community trying
to or claiming that they are helping but
the US is the best example
no still making business okay in a lot
of ways the country's military is real
power broker right now they're they're
backing Maduro but there has been a
revolt by the national guard this week
our significant elements of the military
prepared to back one Guido surely
military is always in such a
constellation a key issue and we have it
we had on Monday this small revolt if I
have to put it very clear no they're not
beckoning the opposition right now
because midoriya has to dig his finger
on the oil and his finger on the trigger
also because this oil money is spreading
into the military so the military
receive support from Medora this revolt
on Monday it showed something
interesting anyway it was that those
militaries after they gave up they were
dialoguing in with high ranks and they
were saying that their situation was bad
Venezuela is really suffering from from
shortages and the military also said
that could be a key issue but until
today the military is supporting Nicolas
Maduro who has his finger on the notary
and the oil good way of putting it
Eduardo Mendez from DW Latin America
thanks you very much for coming in today
you